okay here we go i'm gonna have to talk
fast so we aren't late for the assembly
but
here's the question this is uh which
question is it
13c okay now hands up have you got it
anyone yeah okay all right now it's
doable okay
but it does look weird
especially this guy okay so i'm gonna
walk you through a strategy of how you
would do it now most people
the default way is you're gonna start
with this left hand side which is fine
okay left hand side equals and then you
differentiate
and you use quotient rule providing you
remember that it's a quotient
and then you should end up with when
you've got your u and your v and you
resolve it all out i think you get down
to this
i think that's what you get down to okay
now i could go a little further if i
want to okay because this will become
cos squared minus 2 sine x cos x plus
sine squared you're like i've got a cos
squared plus sine squared there that's
good so they equal 1 and you're left
with a 2 sine x cosine which you can
also simplify it becomes sine 2x now
ordinarily i think that would be better
however we're not just trying to
simplify mindlessly we're actually
trying to get through something specific
and getting a sine 2x down here
no 1 plus sine 2x
is not getting us toward this at all
okay now admittedly when you get down to
this you're like what do i do how on
earth do i introduce something like
pion4 in there okay so i do not blame
you if you look at this
spot and you do a dummy spin okay
however
the reason why this is a they give you
the result and they say okay prove this
is because they're trying to lead you
toward a particular direction that you
would not usually guess on your own
so here's the way that i would approach
it okay i'm stuck at this point
so i'm going to say
if i can't go any further on the left
let's see what i can do with the right
now
just be careful with this i'm going to
give a caution for this that what i'm
going to write on this side is not part
of my proof but it's me trying to work
out what kind of steps can i take
so sector squared
okay
we know that sec is one over cos
okay so this is really this
okay
now that in turn is really this uh let's
see so i've got cos pound 4 plus x and
that whole thing is squared okay now
that's promising i've got something over
something squared that's already looking
like i'm sort of on the right track so
these things should connect okay
now i have two terms here two wave
functions and i only have one here well
you guys know how to turn one into two
you're going to expand just use the
regular old expansion so you're going to
get what's inside here
this is this is cos a plus b
so you're going to get cos cos minus
sine
sine yes
right so then you just fill in your
values you'll have pi on 4
x pi on 4
x
okay
but both of these are equal to 1 on root
2. so i can factorize them out
one on root two
cos minus sign that's suspicious isn't
it okay
now that root two there that's going to
become a half but when you divide by a
half you're really multiplying by two
now remember i said
this is not my proof at this point you
cannot go home and say
you know i'm done i've proved it okay
because what they're really saying is
this statement here is like saying look
get me from a to b okay this is what i
was saying before right you would fire a
taxi driver if you said get me from a to
b and he's like yeah it's cool i'll meet
you there at sea and i'll you know pay
me 80 bucks right um you need to get
from one side to the other
this is not enough
however
getting from one side to the other is
just taking this and putting it in
reverse over here right so you would do
this you'd go well that's two over
um one on root two cos x minus sign now
hold on so it's one
uh all squared now hold on a second
you're like
never in a million years would i think
of
putting that two down here as a square
root and then squaring who would think
of doing that
answer you would if you knew this was
where you had to entertain
so you're going to continue putting the
rest